والاصدقاء في الغرب والشرق انا ما اظن
للسلام والخير والتعاون والبناء بما يحقق
مصالح شعوبنا ويصون حقوق امتنا
[موسيقى]
اخبار جزيره مرحبا بكم اختتام القمه
العربيه الثانيه 32 التي عقدت في مدينه
جده السعوديه بحضور الرئيس الاوكراني
والبيان الختامي للقمه يؤكد اهميه تكثيف
الجهود للتواصل لتسويه عادله للقضيه
الفلسطينيه وعلى وقف التدخلات الخارجيه في
الشؤون الداخليه للدول العربيه
ودعا اعلان جده لتعزيز ظروف المناسبه
لعوده اللاجئين السوريين والحفاظ على وحده
وسلامه الاراضي السوريه كيف تقول انها صدت
هجمات روسيه بالصواريخ والطائرات المسيره
ونائبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني تقول ان
القوات الروسيه تقدمت في باخموت لكنها لا
تسيطر عليها في حين تعلن السلطات المواليه
لروسيا اسقاط مسيرات استهدفت الجزء
الشمالي من شبه جزيره القرم وموسكو تقول
ان التفجيري جسر القرم ونورد سليم تم
بالتنسيق مع المخابرات الامريكيه بعد
عاما على سرقته من مدينه القدس المحتله
جندي اسرائيلي سابق يدعى يائير باراك يعيد
مفتاح باب المغاربه احد ابواب الجدار
الغربي للمسجد الاقصى المبارك ويقول انه
قرر اعادته الى اصحابه لشعوره بعدم
الارتياح لان المفتاح ليس من حقه مسؤوله
في وزاره المساواه الاسبانيه تعلن عن خطه
لانشاء تطبيق الكتروني مجانيا يعالج مشكله
عدم التوازن بين الجنسين في الاعمال
المنزليه يمكن الرجال والنساء من تسجيل
عدد الساعات التي يقضونها في ممارسه هذه
الاعمال بهدف تسطيط الضوء على المهام التي
تؤديها المراه في البيت
الى اللقاء